So in the midst of everything going on with
the virus, the 2020 census is also going on.
And there are already discussions of does
the census need to be delayed?
What do we do?
I got my census form last week and I filled
it out.
I have to tell you, I don't know that I filled
it out correctly.
I don't know that I answered the questions
correctly because of the way that a lot of
this stuff is structured.
I'll explain to you my confusion.
I tweeted about this and a ton of people opined
on how I filled out my census form.
So there's a question which asks, are you
of Hispanic, Latino or Spanish origin now
ethnically?
I'm an Ashkenazi Jew with Eastern European
ancestry and I was born in Argentina.
I my first language is Spanish.
I moved to the U.S. as an immigrant.
One of the options for this question about
being Hispanic or Latino in origin is, yes,
another Hispanic, for example, Colombian,
Ecuadorian and presumably Argentinean.
So I checked.
Yes, I am Hispanic of other origin.
And when it has you fill in the detail.
I put Argentina so far so good.
Then it gets to what is your race?
White, black or African-American?
American Indian or Alaska.
Native, Chinese, Vietnamese.
Some other Asian or some other race.
Now, if you select white, you have to say
what kind of white, what flavor of white are
you?
And as examples, it says Irish or German.
Of course, this is confusing because Irish
and German are also nationalities as much
as they can be.
Niceties it could apply to either.
It's sort of a mess.
Now, the question of whether Jews are white
is a whole other thing.
You have a lot of people who say Jews are
white because they pass as white.
Although what about Ms. Rahim and other Jews?
White supremacists love to say no, Jews are
definitely not white.
Because if we say they're white, they're like
us.
If not white, then it would be some other
race.
So in the end, I put yes, I am white, and
for the type of white I wrote in Ashkenazi
Jewish, did I do this correctly?
Should I have put in other race Ashkenazi
Jewish, which of course gets to Ashkenazi
being an ethnicity?
Not not really a race.
So in short, I have no idea if I filled out
my own census form correctly, but it's an
opportunity to remind you.
Fill out the census.
As of right now, we don't have any indication
the census is being postponed, delayed or
canceled.
It's quick.
It's really important.
I mean, take it's five minutes maybe.
I think it was more like a minute, 90 seconds.
I know a lot of other things are going on.
The virus, people working from home, losing
jobs, et cetera.
When you get the form, take the 90 seconds,
fill it out.
You can do it online or you can fill it out
on paper and mail it back.
And let me know.
Did I fail my own census form, which would
be very embarrassing.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show, we'll
be asking people about their census forms.
You can also follow me at David Pakman and
I have a video of my new home working setup
where you can see all of the monitors and
everything that's going on in here.
That's on Instagram.
David got
The David
Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.